شكرا رشا سائق اخباريه جديده من العربيه
نخصص معظمها لتطورات مشهد في السودان
والحرب في اوكرانيا لكن البدايه بالعناوين
دوي في جرارات في الخرطوم وتجدد
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في محيط المطار
الامم المتحده تكشف عن مقتل وجرح سبعه
اطفال كل ساعه بسبب الاقتتال في السودان
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
لافروف يتوعد بالرد على استهداف الكرملين
ويتهم بتنفيذ الهجوم بضوء اخضر غربي
سجال يتجدد بين قاده روسيا العسكريين قائد
فاجنر يهدد بالانسحاب من باخموت والسبب
نقص الذخيره
[موسيقى]
ما انساد الهدوء العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم حتى تجدد القصف انفجارات دوت
واشتباكات اندلعت بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش رغم الهدنه ودعوه التهدئه فيما
شوهدت اعمده الدخان في محيط منطقه مطار
الخرطوم وسمعت اصوات المضادات الارضيه في
مناطق عده شرق العاصمه ومع استمرار
المواجهات يزداد الضغط على القطاع الصحي
فحسب وزير الصحه السوداني الامدادات
الطبيه تاثرت بشكل كبير بسبب الاقتتال
الحاصل
قبل ذلك اكدت قوه الدعم السريع في بيان
قبولها تمديد الهدنه لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
بوساطه سعوديه امريكيه والالتزام بوقف
اطلاق النار كما اعلن الدعم السريع ترحيبه
بالمبادرات المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه
لوقف اطلاق النار بهدف فتح ممرات انسانيه
وتسهيل حركه المواطنين
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنه في السودان اعلن
الجيش السوداني في بين له عن احباط هجوم
لقوات الدعم السريع على مدينه الاوبيض
شمال كردفان حيث توجد ثاني اكبر حاميه
عسكريه في البلاد وفرض سيطره كامله على
المدينه واوضح البيان ان قوه من الجيش
اشتبكت مع الدعم السريع وكبدتهم خسائر
كبيره في الارواح مع تدمير ثلاث مركبات
واضاف الجيش السوداني ان الدعم السريع شان
هجوما على معسكر تدريب في جبل كردفان اسفر
عن مقتل 15 عسكريا بينهم اثنان من الضباط
كما لاحقت مجموعات من الهجانه التابعه
للجيش عناصر الدعم السريع في عدد من شوارع
وازقه المدينه وفق البيان
نتعرف على اخر التطورات الميدانيه في
الخرطوم مع مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
اهلا بك سالم
اهلا ابراهيم تفضل اخر التطورات موجوده
الان هي انه بدات تسمع بعض مضادات
الطائرات متفرقه هنا في محيط مطار الخرطوم
الدوليه وبالقرب كذلك من القياده العامه
للجيش لكنها باصوات متقطعه ومتباعده كذلك
هناك هدوء في هذه المناطق في منطقه شرق
الخرطوم وكذلك المناطق الجنوبيه من
الخرطوم كذلك الى حد ما هنالك هدوء نسبي
تجددت الاشتباكات قبل ثلاث او اربع ساعات
من الان وكان نتيجتها حريق هائل
الى هذا الخبر العاجل
الخارجيه السودانيه تطالب المجتمع الدولي
بتصنيف الدعم السريع منظمه ارهابيه
بالتعليق على هذا العاجل اذا ما اعتبرت او
دعت الخارجيه السودانيه تصنيف الدعم
السريع منظمه ارهابيه الى اي ماذا سيعقد
هذا الامر جهود التفاوض مع قوات الدعم
السريع
نعم هي في هذا البيان كذلك تحدثت ابراهيم
عن خروقات الدعم السريع تحدثت في هذا
البيان عن حديثها عن الانتهاكات التي تقوم
بها قوات الدعم السريع في هذا البيان
تحدثت عن خروقات تتعلق بالمستشفيات
والصيدليه المركزيه وغيرها من الخروقات
التي يعني تهدد المواطن السوداني بشكل عام
في هذا البيان تحدثت الخارجيه على انه
بناء على هذه المعطيات يجب تصنيف الدعم
السريع كمنظمه ارهابيه يمكنني انعكس ذلك
على جهود التفاوض بانه ما زالت الحكومه
والجيش السوداني متمسكان بمبدا اللا حوار
مع هذه الفئه المتمرده بحسب ما توصف وما
يصف الجيش السوداني بانها قوه متمرده
وخارجه على القانون وانها تقوم بانتهاكات
متكرره لذلك يجب التعامل معها بحسب وما
هذا يعزز من موقف الحكومه هو موقف الجيش
كذلك
نعود الى تطورات الميدانيه لتستكمل كنت
تتحدث عن تجدد الاشتباكات في محيط منطقه
المطار تفضل
نعم ابراهيم بالنسبه للتطورات الميدانيه
ابرزها هذه الاشتباكات التي هي بين الفين
والاخرى وظلت تستمر على الفترات الماضيه
بكل يوم تتجدد هذه الاشتباكات لا جديد في
هذا الموضوع في موضوع الاشتباكات الجديد
فقط انه يعني تزيد الخطوره كلما امتدت
الايام كلما زادت هذه الايام تزيد الخطوره
او تزداد الخطوره على المواطنين لان
المناطق الاشتباكات بعد ان كانت محصوره في
مناطق بدات تتوسع هذا ما نلاحظه كل يوم
بان هنالك منطقه تدخل جديده كذلك في دائره
الاشتباكات والمناطق الاكثر خطوره ربما
هذا ما يرفع ناقوس الخطر لدى المواطنين
بنظرتهم لان الامر اصبح يشكل خطرا وهو كان
مشكلا لخطر في على حياتهم لكن تزداد هذه
النسبه اكثر بتوسع دائرات دائره
الاشتباكات كل مره من مكان الى مكان اخر
هذه النقطه الاولى هذه الحرب تز ايضا هذه
الفاتوره على المواطن الشكاوى من
المواطنين فيما يتعلق بالامداد الغذائي
فيما يتعلق بذلك بالامداد الدواء الان
الامداد بالنسبه للمواد البتروليه كذلك
وكذلك حتى على المستوى الاقتصادي السيوله
النقديه واحده من المعضلات التي تشكل
مشكله الان لدى المواطن كل هذا يجعل مواطن
ولايه الخرطوم على الاقل يشعر باختناق
وواضح من كل الاتجاهات اعداد او حصيله
الضحايا يعني الامم المتحده كشفت عن مقتل
وجرح سبعه اطفال كل ساعه بسبب الاقتتال في
السودان هل في الامر مبالغه في هذا الرقم
ام انه ربما يعني حقيقي
يصعب الحديث عن ارقام حقيقيه بالضبط في
هذه الظروف التي يعيشها مواطن ولايه
الخرطوم بل مواطنه السودان بشكل عام هي
ظروف صعب فيها التواصل نفسه الان شبكتين
من شبكات الاتصالات اصبحت واحده مؤكده
انها خارج الخدمه والاخرى متذبذبه تماما
بقيت شبكه واحده وهي شبكه زين في ظل عدم
التواصل القدره على التواصل بشكل جيد عدم
القدره على الحركه في شوارع وطرق كثيره
جسور كثيره مغلقه يصعب الحديث عن رقم
بالضبط لكن ما هو مؤكد ان هنالك ضحايا وان
هنالك اصابات والمستشفيات التي ما زالت
تعمل مليئه بالارقام ومليئه بالاسماء
للمصابين وكذلك لضحايا هذه الحرب وللذين
قتلوا في هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا فقط نلفت
الانتباه كنا نشاهد هذه الصور المباشره في
كاميرا العربيه والخاصه من العاصمه
الخرطوم خلال حديثنا معك شكرا جزيلا لك
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه كنت معنا
مباشره من الخرطوم
اذا كما تحدث سالم اعلن شركه الاتصالات ام
تي ان توقف خدماتها في الخرطوم عن العمل
وذلك بسبب توقف مقاسم الشركه في الخرطوم
عن العمل ما ادى لانقطاع لجميع الخدمات عن
المشتركين جرائم قطاع الامداد الكهربائي
وقالت شركه انها تعمل على استعاده خدماتها
وايجاد حلول في اقرب وقت
قال وزير الماليه السوداني جبريل ابراهيم
في بيان له حول جهود مجلس الوزراء ازاء
الوضع الحالي في السودان قال ان مجلس
الوزراء يبذل كل الجهود مع اطراف الصراع
لتوفير المواد التموينيه والوقود في
البلاد مشيرا الى تشكيل لجنتين من قبل
المجلس موضحا ان اللجنه الاولى خاصه
بالطوارئ الانسانيه والثانيه مختصه
بمتابعه ثياب السلع والخدمات اللازمه
واشدد ابراهيم في البيان على اهميه فتح
ممرات امنه لوصول الكوادر الطبيه وغيرهم
من الموظفين لمباشره اعمالهم
تتواصل تداعيات الحرب الدائره بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع حيث لقي شاب وطفله
مصرعهما في مدينه ام درمان وجرح خمسه
اخرون اثر سقوط مقذوفه على منزل بحي
الشريفا او الشرفيه امس الاول نحن الان
نتواجد في مدينه ام درمان تحديدا حي
الشرفيه لعكس احدى التداعيات الانسانيه
جراء هذه الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات
الدعم السريع تحديدا في حي الشرفيه سقطت
قذيفه في هذه المنطقه تماما وهذه اثار
الشظايا على هذا الباب وعلى هذه السيارات
التي ادت الى مقتل اثنين احداهما طفله
والاخر شاب بعمر السادسه والعشرين وكذلك
ادت الى جرح خمسه اخرين جميعهم الان
يتلقون العلاج واحدهم يتاثر بجراح بجراحه
البالغ وكذلك ادت الى انقطاع السلك الضغط
العالي للكهرباء الذي كذلك يعني
عولج بمجهودات شعبيه من
المواطنين ومن المهندسين في غرفه الطوارئ
هنا في ام درمان والذي شهيد الحمد لله
اه يا حمودي
[موسيقى]
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
الله يرضي الله انا لله وانا اليه راجعون
انا لله وانا اليه راجعون زي ما حرقوا
قلبي الله يحرق قلوبهم ولدي شافعي شبابه
الحمد لله الحمد لله
في حي الشرفيه
اسر غزيفه طائشه ماما معروف مصدره وين
ظائف العربيه
وفي
الحيطه بتاعه الشارع
واننا جيران برضه مصابين لا عندنا قرش لا
عندنا تعريب ولا عندنا اي حاجه والله
قطعته معايشنا والله العظيم
الولد مات جوه البيت يعني احنا تعبانه جدا
جدا
كيف رصدتم حركه طالبي اللجوء في بورد
سودان هل هي في زياد وهل هناك من يستقر من
السودانيين في المدينه
نعم ابراهيم هي حركه كبيره جدا وتدفقات
كبيره لطالبي المغادره من السودان وكذلك
ايضا المواطنين السودانيين الذين حضروا
الى هذا المكان الامن اكرر ان هذا المكان
بالنسبه للبعثات الدبلوماسيه وبالنسبه
ايضا
للعاملين في قطاع السفارات في السلكه
الدبلوماسي وكذلك في منظمات الغوص وكذلك
المنظمات التي تعمل في مجال العون
الانساني جميع هؤلاء جاؤوا الى هذا المكان
على اعتبار ان الامن هنا في هذه المنطقه
هو العنوان الابرز
اعيد معك مساله الاحصائيات وهذا يؤشر الى
حجم التدفقات الكبيره بالنسبه
لطالبي المغادره الى هذا المكان بلغ عدد
الرحلات البحريه من هذا الميناء من
بورسودان 31 رحله منذ الثاني والعشرين من
ابريل اي قبل اسبوعين من الان وكذلك
ذلك رحلات تعبر عن طريق مطار بورسودان
تقلع من مطار بورسودان الى مناطق اخرى
بالتحديد الى مطار جده وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن اعداد كبيره جدا وتدفقات كبيره جدا
لطالبيه المغادره من السودان على اي حال
في الجانب الاخر في الجانب الذي اقف منه
الان هنالك الميناء الاخضر هذا الميناء هو
الذي تتم منه عمليه التفويج وعمليه تحريك
السفن اخر الاخبار ربما نحن نحتاج الى
تصريح امني للدخول الى تلك المنطقه وهذا
ما نعكف عليه حتى الان للظهور مباشر من
تلك
المنطقه ابراهيم ولكن ما اريد ان اؤكد
عليه واشير له ايضا ان اخر الرحلات التي
ستتحرك بعد قليل من ميناء بورسودان هي
البارجه العسكريه الاسبانيه التي وصلت الى
ميناء بورسودان مساء الامس وستتحرك بعد
قليل بعد الوصول الى العدد الذي تم
التصديق له بمغادره السودان هذه البارزه
ستتحرك بعد قليل اس بي اس
رينا صوفيا هذه البارده الاسبانيه التي
ستنقل اكثر من 200 شخص من رعايه دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا اخر التحديث وصل
الينا قبل قليل قبل ان ننفذ معك هذا
المباشر ابراهيم ابرز الدول التي تعنى
ربما نقل الطالبي اللجوء والمهاجرين هناك
السعوديه تقود هذه الجهود شاهدنا بوارج
امريكيه وسفن حربيه والان تتحدث عن سفينه
ربما تتصدر السعوديه بالتسعه عشره رحله
لكن باقي الدول ابرز هذه الدول التي تم
رصدها
الى اي مدى هناك دول تتواصل مع سفاره
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لتنسيق ترحيل
رعاياها من خلال السفن التي ربما ترسلها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبذلك ربما
تستعيد عن ارسال سفنها لاجلاء رعاياها كون
المملكه العربيه السعوديه موجوده في بورت
سودان وبدات هذه العمليه وربما لديها
القدرات
ولوجستيه اقرب الى جده من اي منطقه اخرى
نعم صحيح يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تقوم بمجهود كبير جدا على مستوى القطع
البحريه والسفن البحريه والبارجات البحريه
التي تصل الى ميناء بورسودان حقيقه اظهرت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مجهودات كبيره
جدا وقدرات كبيره جدا في عمليه الاجلاء
صحيح ان هنالك تنسيق على مستوى عالي جميع
هذه الدول هي تطلب
يعني المغادره
لرعاياها من هنا من مدينه على اعتبار ان
هذا المكان هو مكان امن كما تحدث هنالك
عدد من سفراء الاتحاد الاوروبي هم موجودون
هنا في مدينه بورسودان وكذلك ايضا سفراء
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي كذلك هم موجودون
هنا وحقيقه عدد من السفراء المعتمدين لدى
الخرطوم هم موجودون هنا في مدينه بورسودان
ويباشرون اعمالهم ويتم تقديم للسفاره
السعوديه طبعا هذا مفهوم على اعتبار ان
يعني جده هي المنفذ البحري القريب جدا من
ميناء بورسودان وبالتالي عمليه الاجلاء
ربما تكون يسيره وسهله وغير يعني صعبه
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث الان عن احتماليه
لتدفقات جديده على اعتبار ان رقعه الصراع
الدائر رقعه الحرب في الخرطوم ربما تكون
قد ازدادت بعد العمليات العسكريه التي
تقوم بها المسلحه في محيط القياده العامه
وكذلك ايضا شارع القصر وبالتالي هذا يعني
ربما مزيد من التدفقات لطالبي المغادره
الى ولايه البحر الاحمر بالتحديد الى
مدينه بورسودان محمد عثمان كنت معنا
مباشره شكرا جزيلا لك
حضرت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله يونيسف
من ان المعارك الدائره في السودان منذ
ثلاثه اسابيع تحصد اروع ارواحها اطفال
باعداد كبيره مرعبه مشيره الى ان التقارير
تفيد بسقوط سبعه اطفال كل ساعه بين قتيل
وجريح كما افادت منظمه الاماميه بمقتل 190
طفلا واصابه
1700 اخرين بجروح خلال اول 11 يوما فقط من
القتال مشيره الى ان هذا يعني ان الارقام
لا تغطي صور الاطفال الذين وصلوا الى
مرافق الرعايه الصحيه في تلك المناطق
ومحذرين من ان الواقع قد يكون اسوا بكثير
طلبت مفوضيه الامم المتحده اللاجئين الدول
المستقله بعدم اعادتهم الى بلادهم بسبب
الصراع كما افادت بيانات مفوضيه الساميه
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين بان اخر
الاحصاءات الوارده من وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه تظهر تدفق اكثر من 56 الف شخص الى
البلاد فيرارا من صراع السودان حتى الرابع
مما يؤى الجاري وفق مكتب المفوضيه فان من
بين هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين دخلوا البلاد من
معبري ارجين وخص الملا يقل عن
52,500 سوداني ونحو 4000 من جنسيات اخرى
اكد مبعوث رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي
السفير ضف على الحاجه العربيه ان الجيش
السوداني قبل الهدنه لاسباب انسانيه
وتقديرا للظروف الصعبه التي يعاني منها
السودانيون بسبب الاشتباكات بين قوه الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي ومنظمه الايجاز واكدوا وقوفهم
معنا ومع القوات المسلحه السودانيه
والحكومه السودانيه تحدثوا عن الهدنه ذكرت
لهم اننا
وفي
الخرطوم
وان السيد الرئيس هو الذي بادر اكثر من
مره بل استجاب ايضا لبعض المقترحات من بعض
الدول بالموافقه على الهدنه تقديرا للظرف
الانساني لمواطنين الذين تعرضوا للترويع
وللتخويف
ولمنعهم من الاحتياجات الاساسيه الاساسيه
بواسطه قوات الدعم السريع هو الذي وافق
الان ايضا وافق على المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه للهدنه
كما شدد مبعوث مجلس السياده السوداني
السفير رفع الله الحاج في مقابله حصريه مع
العربيه على عدم قبول اي مقترحات لبحث
موضوع المصالحه مع قوات الدعم السريع
مؤكدا ان اولويه الجيش تكمن في حسم
المعركه ضد قوات الدعم السريع
تمرد
وهذا امر داخلي
سيحل داخليا ان شاء الله لا يمكن ان يكون
هنالك حوار مباشر مع من تمرد الاولويه هي
لحسم هذا التمرد بواسطه القوات المسلحه
السودانيه
وقبل قليل اوضح الجيش السوداني انه قبل
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه لمناقشه
ومراقبه اليه الهدنه في جده من دون لقاء
وفد قوات الدعم السريع
سيغادر وفدنا الى جده
ولن يلتقي انا اوضح بشكل واضح بشكل مباشر
مع الوفد الذي سترسله قوات الدعم السريع
لهذا الغرض وانما سيكون هنالك تواجد غير
مباشر انما المباشر سيكون مع الميسرين
وهما المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للاتفاق على تفاصيل الهدنه مده الهدنه على
الممرات الامنه التي سوف يتم الاتفاق
عليها الايصال المواد التي يحتاجها
مواطنين الذين اشرت انهم يعانون
معاناه كبيره بسبب احد ومنع قوات الدعم
السريع لاحتياجاتهم الاساسيه
انضم الينا من دونمان الصحفي في مكتب
العربيه في السودان شهد نادر اهلا بك شهدي
نفهم من تصريحات السفير دفع الله بان
الوفد الذي سيتوجه من الجيش الى جده
للتباحث مع
المندوبين هناك لن يلتقي مباشره قوات
الدعم السريع وان الحديث سيدور فقط حول
الهدنه والممرات الامنه اما موضوع
المصالحه فهو غير مطروح هل هذا الامر دقيق
ام انه قابل للتغيير عند وصول ربما الوفد
التابع للجيش
مرحبا هذه التصريحات تاتي متماشيه
ومتناسقه مع تصريحات سبقت من عضوي مجلس
السياده الفريق ياسر العطاء وكذلك الفريق
شمس الدين كباشي الذي اكد بان التفاوض
سيكون في شق انساني ولن يتم التطرق الى ما
يجري من عمليات على على الارض اذا هي ربما
هي رساله حملها المبعوث من قبل القياده
العسكريه قياده القوات المسلحه الى
الوساطه الامريكيه السعوديه الى الجانبين
بانه ما يمكن التفاوض حوله هو هو الاشقاء
الانساني هو من اجل الاعمار الانسانيه
تعلم عزيزي بان
التواصل هذه العمليات على مدى اليوم هي في
يومها التاسع عشر افرزت واقع انساني صعب
يمضي من سيء الى اسوا في مناحي عده الان
اليوم كما تعلم توقف في احدى شركات
الاتصالات واصدرت بيان قالت بان خرجت عن
عن الخدمه لدرجه نسبه لعدم استقرار التيار
الكهربائي لصعوبه رئيس الوقود الى
المولدات حتى تستطيع المقسمات خوادم
المقسمات
ان تجعل المشتركين
المستقلين هذه الخدمه داخل داخل شبكه
الاتصالات كذلك لحقت بها شركه سوداني هي
ايضا هي شركه اخرى اصدرت بيان قالت ان
الظروف وعدم استقرار الكهرباء وصعوبه
الحصول على الوقود نتتاثر بعض المناطق
بعدم استقرار الخدمه التي تشهد فيها في
حقيقه الامر اعظم استقرار منذ صباحا اليوم
ثم التذبذب في الاتصالات والانترنت ما
يعمل الان هو شبكه
واحده
طيب بالعوده الى حديث عن الممرات الامنه
في العاصمه السودانيه تحديدا خلال هذه
الهدن التي يتم الموافقه عليها هل تتبلور
بالفعل ممرات امنه يتحرك من خلالها ربما
النازحون الذين يخرجون او من يريد التوجه
الى المشافي او ربما التزود بالمواد
الرئيسيه هل هناك ملامح ممرات رغم عدم
وجودها فعليا على الارض لكن هل هناك طرق
ابتدعها المجتمع المدني خلال هذه
المواجهات لكي تكون بعيده عن مناطق
الاشتباك
كما تعلم بان السودانيين الذين اضطروا
للخروج هم خاطروها وخرجوا ولكن ظلت قالبيه
منظمات المجتمع المدني تشكو من وتجدد
مطالبها حول ضروره فتح مسارات امنه ومناطق
معزوله السلاح حتى تتمكن من القيام
باعمالها الانسانيه سوافي مباشره علاج
داخل المستشفيات امداد المستشفيات
بالمعينات الطبيه كما تعلم بان اللجنه
الدوليه للصليبه الاحمر كانت قد اعلنت عن
وصول مواطنبيه تخص العمليات الجراحيه
واحتياجات المستشفيات حواليه ثمانيه اطنان
قالت انها ما تزال في ميناء بورسودان على
تشرق تحتاج الى مسارات امنه حتى تقوم
بايصال هذه هذه المعينات الى المستشفيات
الخدمه الاولى منظمات مجتمع مدني قيادات
سياسيه كثيرون اشاره الى ضروره فتح مسارات
امنه اشاروا لا ضروره الالتزام بتحديد
مسارات من اجل الاعمال الانسانيه كما تعلم
بان العاصمه تربط ما بينها جسور هذه
الجسور ظلت هي بالقرب من مناطق مناوشات
عسكريه
مستمر هذا الامر يعقد من عمليه
الصحفي في مكتب العربيه كنت معنا عبر
الهاتف من ام درمان نشير مشاهدينا الاخبار
العاجل التي وردت قبل قليل محمد حمدان
قائد قوات الدعم السريع يؤكد انه تلقى
اتصالا هاتفيا من وزير خارجيه مصر يتعلق
بالاوضاع في السودان واكد احمدتي بانه
ناقش مع وزير خارجيه مصر المبادرات
المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه بشان الوضع
في السودان اذا حميدت يتلقى اتصالا هاتفيا
مع وزير خارجيه مصر بشان اخر التطورات في
السودان
والمبادرات ذات الصله
يعرقل القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في السودان جهود العمل الانساني لا
سيما الوصول الى المناطق المتضرره لمساعده
المحتاجين في بلد كان ثلث سكانه يعانون من
الجوع اساسا قبل هذه الحرب
اغاثه السودان هدف منظمات العمل الانساني
لكن حاله الانفلات الامني المتصاعده منذ
اسابيع تعيق ذلك
صعوبات عده تقف امام منظمات الاغاثه
الدوليه ابرزها احتدام القتال بين طرفي
الصراع رغم الهدن الممتده غياب ضمانات
الامنيه لمسارات قوافذ الاغاثه وصعوبه
تحديد المواقع المتضرره ومن يسيطر عليها
فبين القصف العنيف في العاصمه الخرطوم
ونيران القتال في دارفور تبحث فرق منظمات
الدوليه عن طرق امنه ومسارات تضمن لها
ايصال المساعدات الملحه من الامدادات
الطبيه والغذائيه الى المدنيين العالقين
وبشكل عاجل منظمه اطباء بلا حدود مستوى
العنف الذي سجل في الخرطوم ودارفور ضد
المدنيين ومتطوعي العمل الانساني مقلق اما
عن غياب ضمانات الامنيه فالامم المتحده
ناشدت عده مرات طرفي النزاع من الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع بتوفير ضمانات امنيه
تحمي قوافل المساعدات بعد تكرر عمليات
النهب بشاحنات مساعد الاغاثيه فوفقا
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي التابعي للامم
المتحده ان نحو 17 الف طن من المساعدات
الانسانيه اي ما قيمته نحو 14 مليون دولار
تعرضت للنهب منذ اندلاع القتال في السودان
ومن الصعوبات التي تعرقل عمل منظمات
الانسانيه معرفه من من الطرفين المتنازعين
يحكم سيطرته في تلك المنطقه او تلك سواء
في العاصمه الخرطوم او في دارفور غربا
الامر الذي دفع بعض منظمات الاغاثه الى
التوجه الى مدينه بورتسودان التي تشهد
هدوءا نسبيا واستفوضى في اماكن اخرى
بالبلاد لتصبح المدينه نقطه الدخول
لامدادات المساعدات الدوليه ومركزا لعشرات
الالاف الذين يتطلعون الى الفرار من
القتال
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
امتدت تاثيرات الحرب الدائره في السودان
على المغتربين السودانيين في الرياض التي
يجتمع بها اكثرهم يواسي السودانيون بعضهم
البعض في الجلوس معا في المقاهي والجمعيات
ويحاولون المساهمه بتخفيف المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني باي وسيله كانت
لم يالفوا حوارات تدور حول قصف وقذائف
تضرب عاصمه بلادهم بخور القهوه الذي
يشاركهم الحديث يذكرهم بالدخان المتصاعد
من ابنيه الخرطوم هكذا انقلبت احوال
الجاليه السودانيه في الرياض من حديث عن
هموم الغربه الى قلق على الوطن
الاوضع سيئه بالنسبه لنا
هنا وكده فالواحد يعني حزين لكن نسال الله
ان ربنا يسهل الامور ويرفع البلاء على
العباد والبلاد ان شاء الله لحتى ما قدرنا
نعيد على عيالنا فهمت علي انه الواحد ما
قدر يصل لعياله عن طريق تليفون ولا عن
طريق اي برامج من برامج التواصل الاجتماعي
في الاماكن العامه والاماكن الخاصه يشترك
سودانيون في هذه الايام بالحديث عن الحرب
ولا غير الحرب حديث لم يعتادوا عليه طوال
العقود الماضيه لكنهم قلقون مما يحدث في
الداخل لسيما وان اهاليهم واصدقائهم لا
زالوا في مدن تضربها النيران
كلما طرفه عيني يرف ضياء
وذكريات احبائي اذا خفرت احس بالموج فوق
البحر يلعب بي مواساه قد تنطق بها ابيات
شعريه وتعبر عنها نظرات الحضور هنا مشهد
القريه حاضر في صلب الاحاديث اخرون
يتسمرون امام الشاشات بحثا عن نهايه لهذا
الكابوس
اعتادوا على التكافل الاجتماعي في
جمعياتهم وتقديم الدعم للمغتربين الجدد
لكنهم شرعوا هذه المره في محاوله تقديم
الدعم المادي لقريتهم في شمال السودان
لمساعده اهاليهم الذين نزحوا من الخرطوم
هربا من الحرب
الان في الخرطوم كل التجاره متوقفه يعني
في اي لحظه اذا استمر
الكيلاج ده لمده شهر حتحصل مجاعه داخل
الخرطوم ناس بالذات المغتربين الموجودين
هنا الكاتبهم هناك ويعني قدروا يعملوا نوع
من النفير على اساس انه يساعده الاسره
العالقه ما قادره ما عندها امكانيه توصل
لاهلها في الشمال الناس يتعاون كل الجمعيه
في حدود اهلها علق الكثير من المغتربين
السودانيين المقيمين في السعوديه في بدايه
الحرب بالخرطوم بعضهم استطاع العوده من
خلال سفن الاجلاء السعودي
فيما يخطط الكثير ممن التقيناهم هنا لجلب
عائلاتهم الى السعوديه في حال استمرار
الحرب عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
الرياض
سهم الجيش السوداني وعلى مر سنوات طويله
في الحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار الداخلي
حتى الحدودي ضمن استراتيجيه عسكريه محكمه
تمكن من خلالها من مواجهه كافه التحديات
والتهديدات الحدوديه المحتمله تفاصيل اكثر
نتابعها مع الزميل فارس صلواتي دور حيوي
مهم لعبه الجيش السوداني منذ استقلال
البلاد في عام
1956 حيث كان الحفاظ على الاستقرار وتهدئه
الاضطرابات الداخليه ومواجهه التحديات
الحدوديه اولويه قصوى مناطق عسكريه ووحدات
قتاليه بريه ونقاط تفتيش عسكريه تابعه
للجيش السوداني موجوده على طول الحدود
التي تربطه بدول الجوار شمالا هنا حيث
الجار مصر توجد مناطق عسكريه تابعه للجيش
السوداني تحديدا جنوب مثلث حلايب في ولايه
البحر الاحمر
يوجد كاتبه الفرقه التاسع عشر بمدينه مروي
والتي تطل على طريق شريان الشمال الرابط
بين مصر والسودان على الضفه المقابله مثلث
اخر على الحدود الليبيه السودانيه هناك
ايضا قاعده مركزيه كبيره للجيش السوداني
اما غربا التشاد وبحدود بريه تزيد عن 2000
كيلومتر مع السودان تنتشر فيها قوات
مشتركه بهدف تامين تلك الحدود فقط
وفي افريقيا الوسطى التي تمزقها الحرب
يوجد الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط تفتيش
عسكريه عند الدخول والخروج اما على الحدود
السودانيه
يمكن والتي يمكن ان تتحول لقاعده لتدفق
السلاح ينتشر الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط
تفتيش كبرى في كسلا والحدود المتاخمه مع
اريتريا ضمن حاميه عسكريه نقطه
هنا وعلى تلك الحدود المشتعله حينا وحين
مع اثيوبيا ينتشر الجيش السوداني في منطقه
الفشقه التي تقع في ولايه الجضارف وايضا
في منطقه الجلابات وولايه النيل الازرق
وفي جنوب البلاد هناك العديد من المناطق
العسكريه ينتشر فيها الجيش السوداني شمال
ابيي وشمال ابيي كما نتابع وكذلك في
كوردوفان وولايه النيل الابيض حدود بريه
واسعه يتشاركها السودان مع دول عديده فرضت
على الجيش اتباع استراتيجيه تحكمها ضوابط
عسكريه لحمايه وتعزيز وجوده على طول
الشريط الحدودي
[موسيقى]
الان الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
اكد وزير الخارجيه روسيس ان الهجوم على
الكرملين كان عملا ادائيا وروسيا سترد
بخطوات ملموسه واعتبر لافروف انا كيف لن
تحاول مهاجمه من دون اخطار سادتها في
الغرب حسب وصفه وكشف وزير الخارجيه الروسي
ايضا ان موسكو مستعده للتحدث مع الغرب
وهذا سيحدث عاجلا ام اجلا
من الواضح انه كان عملا عدائيا ومن الواضح
تماما ان ارهابي كيف لم يكن بامكانهم
ارتكاب هذه الحادثه دون علم القياده
الاوكرانيه لن نرد عما اذا كان ذلك سبب
الحرب ام لا لكننا حتما سنرد بالافعال
ونحن لدينا الكثير من الصبر وبالحديث عن
موقف واشنطن لقد اطلعت على بيان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
الذي قال فيه ان الولايات المتحده لن تملي
على اوكرانيا ما ينبغي فعله اتجاه قيادتها
وهذا يوضح كل شيء
قاده الجيش الروسي مسؤوليه سقوط عشرات
الاف القتلى والجرحى الروس في المدينه قبل
ذلك حضر الرئيس مجموعه فاجنر من ان قوته
ستغادر المدينه في العاشر من مايو الحالي
بسبب عدم تامين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الذخيره لقوته وقال بريكوجين ان استمرار
القتال في مدينه باخمت من دون ذخيره امر
لا جدوى منه
بحلول التاسع من ما يوقن على وشك
الاستيلاء على ضخمه لكن بعد ان راوا هذا
التقدم اوقف البيروقراطيون شبه العسكريين
توريد الذخيره لمنعنا من القيام بذلك
يعتقدون انهم سوف يدخلون التاريخ ابلغت
وزير الدفاع ورئيسها هيئه الاركان والقائد
الاعلى رسميا بان رفاقي لن يتكبدوا خسائر
غير مبرره في باخموت بدون ذخيره لذا في
العشر من مايو سننسحب من
تحافظ الناطق باسم الكرم عن الاجابه حول
سؤال على اخر تصريح لرئيس مرتزقه فاجنر
حول التراجعي من ضخمه
طبعا شاهدنا ذلك في وسائل الاعلام لكن لا
يمكنني التعليق لان الامر يتعلق بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه
انضم الينا موسكو الكاتب السياسي بسام بني
اهلا بك استاذ بسام كيف تعلق على ما حدث
خصوصا فيما يتعلق بتصريحات
باعتقادكم هل احرج القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه لروسيا بهذه التصريحات
اعتقد نعم لان رجاء الرد سريعا اليوم زار
شيبوه وزير الدفاع منطقه الجنوبيه
وتاكد بنفسه من ايصال المساعدات والزخائر
الى كافه الوحدات المقاتله والعامله على
الجبهات ماذا يعني انه تم احراج القياده
بشكل فعلي ولكن هنا نحن في موسكو يعني
نقع في حاله تخبط عندما نسمع مثل هذه
التصريحات لانه منذ اشهر وهو يصرح بانه لا
يتلقى الخزخاء المطلوبه ونلاحظ تقدم
للقوات الروسيه على الارض وقوات
بالذات تتقدر على الارض رغم شكواه من عدم
وصول الزخائن ربما تكون هي عمليه
استخباراتيه ان صح التعبير او عمليه
بروبراغاندا عسكريه من اجل اهام الخصم او
العدو بانه لا يوجد ذخائر من اجل يعني شده
الى الهجوم المضاد في منطقه معينه وربما
تكون بالف عل هناك خلافات لا احد يعلم
الشيء الوحيد الذي اعلمه ان ريحوجن لا
يمكن له ان يتكلم من تلقاء نفسه لانه
موثوق من قبل الرئيس بوتين ويعني هو رجل
بوتين الاول لكن رجل بوتين الاول يهدد
بالانسحاب من باخمت هذا الامر ربما يؤثر
على معنويات القوات الموجوده هناك وربما
هذا امر اخطر من مجريات المعركه على الارض
يعني ربما يؤثر ولكن انا اعتقد ان هناك
مفاجات تخبئها روسيا للعدو الاوكراني اذا
ما حاول القيام بالهجوم المضاد فهل هناك
حديث عن تسع الاف طائره حربيه جاهزه لم
تشارك حتى الان في الاعمال القبليه بشكل
جدي يعني هناك عدد طائرات روسيه قليله
تشاهد تشارك في العمليات اما اذا ما قام
الهجوم المضاد سيقوم سلاح الجو وهو متفوق
جويا في ساحه المعارك بالهجوم على هذه
القوات وفنيها تماما نعود الى تصريحات
وزير الخارجيه الروسي
السؤال انه لماذا تاخر الرد الروسي على
استهداف الكريم
بمسيرتين اتهمت موسكو واشنطن بانها تقف
خلف اوكرانيا وقالت بانه لا يمكن لكييف ان
تقوم بعمل كهذا دون ان تحصل على ضوء اخضر
من اسيادها هذا حسب تعبير موسكو او لافروف
ايضا نائبه صرح تصريحات ناريه بهذا الصدد
وبسكوت صرح تصريحات ناريه بهذا الصدف يعني
كل المسؤولين نفس التصريحات بهذا الصبر
وكلنا نعلم وقد قلنا على قناتكم منذ سنه
واكثر ان المعركه ليست بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا بينما هي المعركه بين روسيا والغرب
وعلى راس الغرب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولا يمكن الحل الا عن طريق
الاتفاق لكن السؤال لماذا تاخر الرد
وباعتقادك متى سيكون هل هو مرتبط
بالاحتفالات بعيد النصر يعني ممكن ان يكون
مرتبط بالاحتفالات ولكن انا تعودت ان لا
اعلق سريعا على الاحداث لان عودنا الرئيس
بوتين عن بطئه في الرد فهناك مثلا روسيا
يقول الانتقام هو عباره عن وجبه تقدم
بارده لا يمكن ان بالمناسبه
[موسيقى]
استكملت السلطات البريطانيه استعداداتها
لحفل تتويج منز الثالث وبهذه المناسبه عاد
الحديث عن تكاليف التتويج وسط الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها البلاد اذ تعتبر
تكلفه العائله الملكه على دافعي الضرائب
موضوعا جدليا في بريطانيا يزداد هذا الجدل
مع اقتراب المراسم والاحتفالات الملكيه
التي تقع على كاهل الموازنه العامه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في يونيو من عام
1953 توجت الملكه اليزابيث الراحله في حفل
كلفه نحو 50 مليون جنيه استرليني واليوم
وبعد 70 عاما تقدر تكلفه تتويج ابنها
بمئه مليون جنيه بحسب لجنه التنظيم
الفاتوره بما فيها التكاليف الامنيه
والحفل الغنائي الضخم في قلعه واسمنسر
تدفعها الحكومه نظرا الى انه حدث دوله
بمعنى ان العب يقع على الموازنه العامه
ودافع الضرائب في ظل ازمه تكلفه معيشه
يعاني منها الملايين
الملك اخذ الوضع الاقتصادي في الاعتبار
وحاول تقليص الفعاليات جزئيا ولكن اعتقد
ان الاغلبيه تؤيد اقامه حفل تتويج مشرف
لان فعاليات التتويج لا تاتي كل سنه او
حتى كل عقد ويجب ان تلتزم بمستوى عال
واحترام للتقاليد والتاريخ
وفي محاوله لمراعاه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
قلل الملك عدد المدعوين الى نحو 2000 مدعو
مقارنه بثمانيه الاف شخص حضروا تتويج
الملك الراحله المراسم الرسميه داخل
الكنيسه واسمنسور
من ثلاث ساعات الى ما بين 90 دقيقه
وساعتين كما خصص الملك يوما يشجع فيه
المواطنين على التطوع والقيام بالاعمال
الخيريه في مجتمعهم للتجديد على اهتمامه
بمساعده الفقراء والمتضررين
الحكومه بدورها تقول ان الحفل سيجلب
مردودا سياحيا ضخما وسيعطي جرعه نشاطا
للاقتصاد كما يشير المسؤولون الى حقوق
البث لقنوات حول العالم التي من المتوقع
ان تحصل الملايين من الجنيهات للموازنه
الاخر حفل تتويج كان قبل سبعين عاما فهو
فعليا حدث تاريخي واذا نظرنا الى احتفالات
اليوبيل البلاتينيه السنه الماضيه نقدر
انه جلب ملياري جنيه من الانفاق في
المطاعم والفنادق وفي منطقه الويست اند في
لندن المبيعات الاضافيه بلغت 80 مليون
جنيه ولا يزال جدل يدور حول الاجازه
الرسميه من مؤيد يقول انها ستدعم الاقتصاد
بنحو مليار جنيه من خلال الاستهلاك
والسياحه ومن معارض يحذر من تكلفه توقف
العمل قد تتجاوز ملياري جنيه ايا كانت
الفاتوره النهائيه لمراسم التتويج يعد
التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه هو
اقامه احتفال يليق بض خامه هذا الحدث
التاريخي ولكن اخذا في الاعتبار الصعوبه
الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها البريطانيون
كارينا كامل العربيه لندن
التقى الامير ويليام وزوجته كيت ميدلتون
بالجمهور المصطفى للسلام على العائله
المالكه البريطانيه وذلك مع اقتراب مراسم
التتويج الرسميه يوم غدا السبت والتي من
المنتظر ان يحضرها عدد كبير من زعماء
العالم لتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث وولي
عهده الامير وليم
وتنضم الينا من لندن مديره مكتب العربيه
ريما مكتبي اهلا بك ريما بدايه لو تضعين
في الاجواء التي تعيشها العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن عشيه حفل تتويج الملك
تشارز الثالث لجهه الاستعدادات الترتيبات
الامنيه وباقي الامور
جميع من هم من حولي في لندن دخلوا في مزاج
التتويج ستكون عطله نهايه اسبوع طويله
وغدا سيكون يوم للتاريخ اقل ما سيشهد
الكثير من البريطانيين والعالم من خلفي من
استر ابي حيث سيكون او ستكون مراسم
التتويج للملك الثالث وهو من اقدم
الملوك الذين بقيوا ولي العهد لاطول فتره
ممكنه يعني انتظر 57 75 عاما ليصبح ملكا
مراسم مهمه جدا في الكثير من الرمزيه
بالكثير من التفصيل وكل تفصيل له تاريخ
عمره مئات السنوات هناك عمليه امنيه ضخمه
اكثر من 29,000 شرطي يؤمنون العاصمه
ويؤمنون حفل التتويج وايضا مداخل
وهناك من نصب الخيام منذ ايام ليكون على
الطريق المؤدي بين قصر باكينغهام وكنيسه
ويسترن
وبالتالي عدد كبير ملايين الناس يشاهدون
هذا الحدث منهم من سياتي بشكل مباشر الى
حرم منستر حيث انا اقف مع انه سيكون هناك
طوق امني كبير والبعض الاخر سيكون على
طرقات المؤديه الملك تشارل سيخلوش سيخرج
من قصر باكينغهام الساعه عشره وثلث بتوقيت
لندن اي تسعه وعشرين دقيقه بتوقيت غرينتش
يخرج من قصر باكينغام باتجاهي وست من السر
سيرافقه الاف القوات المسلحه 7000 عنصر من
القوات المسلحه الفرقه الموسيقيه فقط
ستكون 4000 يصل الى كنيسه ويست مونستر من
خلفي تبدا المراسم 11 بتوقيت لندن يعني 10
بتوقيت جري استمر لقرابه الساعتين هناك
مراحل مهمه للتتويج كل مرحله مهمه وكل
مرحله لها تاريخ ولها رمزيه ولكن مسح
الملك بالزيت هذه عمليه مقدسه سيقوم بها
اسقف
بالخفاء بعيدا عن عدسات الكاميرا وبعيدا
عن اعين الجميع والزيت المقدس سيكون من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله والتي صلى
عليها
الفلسطينيون او الكهنه الفلسطينيون قبل
اشهر ليؤتى بالزيت هنا الى بريطانيا وفي
رمزيه مهمه جدا بالتاكيد الكثير من
التفاصيل المهمه والمثيره
سترافقين غدا لتطلعين عليها اولا باول
خلال هذه المراسم لكن السؤال بانه بعيدا
عن كل الاتهامات وفي كل مره يحدث حفل من
هذا النوع نستمع الى انتقادات تتعلق
بالمكانات وربما التكاليف لكن كيف استعدت
لندن هناك انباء عن وصول الالاف وان
الفنادق محجوزه عن بكره ابيها وان هناك من
وصل سابقا وارتفاع اسعار التذاكر هناك ما
يشبه العرس الذي تعيش بريطانيا لو تضعين
في الاجواء التي سبقت هذا التتويج
والمراسم وكيف انعكس ايجابا على بريطانيا
حتى سائق التاكسي الذي كنت احدث قبل ايام
قال نحن ننتظر التتويج لانه سيدر بعض
الاموال والسواح لنا
الفنادق محجوزه كما قلت الاسعار مرتفعه
اصلا في بريطانيا بسبب التضخم عدد من
السياحه الداخليه نشهدها في الايام
الماضيه السياحه الخارجيه عدد كبير من
كبار الشخصيات والناس العاديين جاؤوا الى
بريطانيا وبعض العرب ايضا ليكونوا هنا في
العاصمه فيما تكون هناك مراسم التتويج
التي قد تحصل مره بالعمر او اقله يشهدونها
مره بالعمر وبالتالي الاجواء بشكل عام
اصبحت ايجابيه جدا
وكانت الشرطه
حازمه جدا مع المعارضين للملاكيه وقالت اي
عمل امني لن يتم التعاون معه وبالتالي
امنوا المدينه نرى الكثير من الشاشات
الضخمه مش بس بوسط لندن حتى بالمنا في
انجلترا وبريطانيا يريدون ان يتابعوا
مراسم التتويج لانه عمليات الوصول لوساه
لندن ليست بسهله هذه العمليه تدور بقرابه
مليار جنيه استرليني للاقتصاد البريطاني
يعني تقريبا مليار وربع دولار مع انه
التكلفه قد تكون ضخمه لكن الملك تشارلز
كان حريصا ان لا يكون ان لا تكون مراسم
متكلفه جدا وثمنها باهظ على غدا سنتابع
معك اولا باول هذه المراسم انا اشكرك على
وجودك معنا مديره مكتب العربيه في لندن
ريما مكتبي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
ارتفعت نسب مبيعات الليرات والانصات من
الذهب في لبنان مع فقدان الثقه بالمصارف
وتخوف اللبنانيين من الازمه الاقتصاديه
العالميه خاصه بعد اندلاع الحرب
الاوكرانيه اللبنانيون يخشون ان تفقد
العمله الورقيه قيمتها حتى وان كانت
عالميه فيتكررت سيناريو وفقدان الليره
اللبنانيه لقيمتها مع عملات اخرى
منذ اربعه اعوام واللبنانيون يبدلون سبل
المحافظه على اموالهم بعد ان خسروا ما
ادخروه داخل المصارف وبعد ان ملات العملات
الصعبه خزائن منازلهم قرروا استبدالها
اليوم بالعمله المعدنيه خاصه الذهب حتى ان
الطلبه ازداد لدرجه فقدت معه الليرات
والانصات من الاسواق ذهب اكيد لا انا ذهب
بدلا قيمته في المصاري عم تطلع ايمتى تنزل
قيمتها
اذا معي مصاري بساعد العالم لو غني انا
فقير ما بشتري لذهب ولا شيء
معروف من الف سنين هو الاساسي بقى واليوم
العمله الورقيه انت بتعرفي وين مكان عم
تتلخبط كلها
95% الاتجاه على الاونصات والليرات لا
ينكروا رئيس نقابه التجار الذهب
والمجوهرات في لبنان
مع بدايه الازمه الاقتصاديه ولكن الاوضاع
تغيرت خاصه بعد اندلاع الحرب الاوكرانيه
حينها تخطى حجمه مبيع الاونصات الاربعين
اونصه يوميا لدى التجار 2022 او قبل شوي
وصلت الاونصه للالف و625 دولار زاد الطلب
وحتى السوق المحلي ما عاد يلبي للسبونات
وللطلبات يعني تصوري اللي بده يشتري كان
قوصات او ليرات يحجز قبل بيومين ثلاثه
اربعه خمسه او يدفع حقهم لبعد اسبوع لا
يستلم من هيك كان في ضغط كتير كتير قوي
على الذهب
اللي ما عليه لا صياغه ولا عليه شغل
العمله المعدنيه الى مدخرات اصحاب
الرساميل الصغيره اما كبار المستثمرين
فيلجاون الى السبائك وكيلوات الذهب بين
العمله الورقيه والليرات الذهب يفضل
اللبنانيون ما يضمن عدم خسارتهم مره اخرى
لمدخلات عادوا لجمعها من الصفر غنو يتيم
العربيه بيروت
هذه الساعه انتهت التغطيه مستمره على راس
السنه مع زميل رشا نبيل تفضلوا بالبقاء
معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات